bonjour à tous alors aujourd'hui un
petit numéro hors-série principalement
pour vous parler du fait que j'ai écrit
un livre et qui sort aujourd'hui le 17
février et donc ça s'appelle mais qui a
attrapé le bison de higgs
alors voilà donc je sais que y'en a qui
vont dire oui encore un youtuber qui
fait un livre qu'est ce que c'est est-ce
que ça va être juste du copier coller
des scripts des vidéos en fait non pas
du tout il ya une bonne raison pour ça
c'est qu'en fait je suis pas un vidéaste
qui écrit un livre en fait c'est plutôt
l'inversé
il faut savoir qu'à la base moi je viens
plutôt de l'écrit ça fait maintenant
plus de cinq ans que je tiens un blog de
vulgarisation scientifique est en fait
ce livre il a été écrit quasiment dans
son intégralité il ya à peu près un an
et demi c'est à dire avant que je
commence à créer des vidéos donc le
livre est en fait complètement
indépendant de ce que j'ai fait sur la
chaîne et j'ai même fait gaffe
comme il était déjà écrit à ne pas
traiter en vidéo trop de choses que
j'avais déjà traités dans le livre donc
si vous regardez en fait il ya 2-3
redite mais bon voilà 90%
c'est des choses que vous n'avez jamais
vu sur la chaîne alors qu'est ce qu'il
ya dans ce livre
eh bien il ya vingt chapitres et chaque
chapitre répond à une question
scientifique qui peut être de la
physique de la chimie de la bio des
matches a même un petit peu de sciences
sociales et donc à chaque fois je
réponds à une question d'une manière
relativement complète à chaque chapitre
fait 8 10 pages avec pas mal de schémas
comme vous avez par exemple habitudes
dans mes vidéos et pour que chaque sujet
soit introduit un peu en douceur en fait
chaque chapitre commence par un dialogue
entre moi et une de mes filles déjà
c'est un petit prétexte pour raconter un
petit peu ma vie et puis à la fin ma
fille à chaque fois est amené à me poser
une question scientifique toujours sous
une forme un petit peu naïve du genre
mais qui a attrapé le bison de higgs et
puis voilà ensuite dans le texte je
réponds à cette question d'une manière
plus sérieuse et plus classique
alors voilà des exemples de deux
chapitres et donc de question on a par
exemple comment sont apparues les
premières petites bêtes ou bien est-ce
que l'intérieur de la terre et liquides
ou encore est-ce que l'univers a
commencé un jour ou bien vous savez que
les atomes et puis très important chaque
chapitre a été illustré par lisons
bernet que vous connaissez peut-être
c'est une illustratrice qui fait
notamment la bd du lhc est en fait c'est
un peu elle la maman du bison de higgs
est donc l a fait en sur chaque chapitre
un petit dessin dans un style assez
onirique que j'aime vraiment beaucoup et
qui se trouve apporte beaucoup au look
graphique du bouquin alors celui du rpt
il est disponible dans tous les bons
endroits où on vend des livres donc ça
peut être votre librairie de quartier si
elle là ça peut être les grandes
enseignes certainement et puis bien sûr
les habituels site de vente en ligne
donc je vous mettrais un lien ici pour
vous renvoyer vers tout ça voilà donc
suis vraiment très curieux de savoir ce
que vous en pensez donc n'hésitez pas à
me laisser des commentaires ici ou
ailleurs
et puis bien sûr il n'était pas non plus
à faire tourner l'information si le
coeur vous en dit alors comme c'est en
plus un numéro un peu hors série j'en
profite pour vous parler de deux chaînes
que j'aime bien et dont je pense qu'elle
mériterait plus d'abonnés voilà c'est
l'occasion donc la première chaîne dont
je voulais vous parler elle s'appelle
patience c'est une chaîne qui traite de
sciences en général mais quand même avec
pas mal de physique fondamentale
donc j'aime bien et puis si vous savez
pas par où commencer je vous recommande
notamment sa vidéo sur le principe de
relativité qui est vraiment très très
bien c'est un principe qui est en
général assez mal compris et là je
trouve qu'ils l'expliquent vraiment très
très bien une autre chaîne que je vous
recommande beaucoup c'est une chaîne qui
s'appelle primum no quéré je suis pas
sûr de commencer à se prononcer du latin
ça veut dire premièrement ne pas nuire
et c'est une chaîne qui parle
essentiellement de biologie et de
médecine surtout de médecine voilà c'est
une chaîne que j'aime là que j'aime bien
et vous pouvez par exemple commencer par
la vidéo sur le dopage qui est très bien
voilà merci d'être toujours de plus en
plus nombreux à suivre la chaîne ça me
fait vraiment très plaisir
donc comme d'habitude n'hésitez pas à la
partager à votre famille à vos collègues
vos amis à vos ennemis aussi si ça vous
amuse et puis je vous dis à bientôt pour
de nouvelles vidéos